- Ladies and gentleman,
put your hands together,
and welcome on stage,
the Chairman of VaynerX.
The one and only, Gary Vaynerchuck!
(audience applause)
Raise the roof!
Come on!
- Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I love you very much.
Sharjah, I'm so excited to be here.
Thank you for having me.
(audience applause)
There's so many things that
I want to cover in this time
so let's just get right into it.
A couple things.
When you grow up the way I did,
and for a lot of people in
this room that don't know,
I'll give you the one minute version
because so much of the
energy I'm feeling here today
across the UAE, and
specifically at this event,
and on social with my interactions, is,
I was born in the former Soviet Union
and then I came to the United States
when I was three years old.
My father worked every minute.
I really didn't spend
a lot of time with him
until I was 14, 15, when I
worked in the liquor store
that he started working
at for $2.00 an hour
as a stock boy and eventually
saved all his money
and bought a store in
Springfield, New Jersey.
I was a product of the
1980's, and 1990's in America,
which I think when people look back on
will be the golden era of education
and what college you
went to basically meant
who you were gonna be in the world.
In the face of education
being the only way out
in the 80s and 90s
especially for an immigrant.
My mother created a framework
that allowed my to flourish
against my own DNA.
My self awareness, who I was,
which was a D and F student.
The worst grades that
you could get in school
but also was a child that
on summer day vacations
or when it snowed, or
whatever was happening,
I was always looking
to be an entrepreneur.
If it snowed in New Jersey,
I was ringing doorbells looking
to get money to shovel snow.
If it was hot outside,
I was setting up a lemonade
stand to sell lemonade.
From the beginning of my life,
I was put in a position,
luckily based on where I was
and who was parenting me,
to actually lean into my strengths,
and the things that I
was passionate about.
It's very interesting
what I'm actually thinking
while I stand here, which is,
here we are 20 years, 30
years later, from that boy,
where now entrepreneurship
gives me the luxury,
gives me the honor to come to
all places around the world
and people treat me with admiration
and respect and kindness.
Ironically, the explosion
of entrepreneurship,
and events like this
and movements like this,
don't excite me as much
as most people think.
I of course, am a student, a product,
and a humongous advocate
of entrepreneurship.
However, that is completely secondary
to my passion around self
awareness and happiness.
It is my great concern, that
the framework, the world,
that has put me on a
pedestal, entrepreneurship,
is going to blind some of you in this room
who are actually unbelievably capable
to be a number two, a number
three, a number seven,
within an organization,
but believe in the hype,
that the only way to
win, or more importantly,
what's cool now, is to be a founder.
I encourage every single
person here who has the stomach
and the mindset for entrepreneurship,
but I implore you, if you take anything
from my keynote today,
please go home and look
yourself in the mirror
and start having unbelievably
honest conversations with yourself,
about who you are, versus
who you wish you were.
Today entrepreneurship, in 2018, 2019,
across the world, is put on a pedestal.
I promise you, today I walk
into an event like this
and everybody wants a selfie,
and I get treated this
way, and it's unbelievable,
but I promise you as I stand here,
I am very mentally prepared for 2027,
when the global economy collapses
and I start getting blamed
for teaching or telling
you to do entrepreneurship
when your startup failed.
For me, this is my life.
When it wasn't cool.
Now while it's cool,
and in a decade when
it won't be cool again.
I want that for you,
because when you do what
you were meant to do,
when you're able to put
two fingers in your ears
and hear nothing.
Not the hate or the negativity,
but equally, not the
admiration and the accolades,
you're playing within yourself.
You're playing within yourself.
My great fear,
my great fear around the world
is how many people here are
not playing for themselves?
They're playing for their parents.
They're playing for their friends.
The things they buy,
the things they start,
the way they live, are predicated
on other people's opinions.
Not themselves.
I'm not coming here to
start with a buzzkill,
but I also do not want to be delusional
to the reality of the situation.
To build a meaningful company
takes a very long time,
is very difficult, and more importantly,
what has happened in
the startup community.
All those wonderful startups back there,
everybody now is pandering
to venture capital
or to raising capital.
Not to actually building a business.
Every day.
Thank you.
It's important.
Thank you so much for jumping on that.
It's important, because
let me tell you why
in 2006, 2007, 2008, 2009,
I was taking all of my money
and investing in Tumblr and Facebook
and Twitter and Uber,
and all these things that
I did very well with,
and why over the last four years,
I've invested very little, very carefully,
because there's a disconnect right now,
and there's illusions of the reality.
If you stand here or sit here today
and there is nothing that
you could think about
other than building a business,
because the process of
building a business,
is your happiness.
Not what a successful
business allows you to buy.
Well then you're a pure
bread entrepreneur.
Somebody asked me today in an interview,
what do I do with my downtime?
I told them that I start other businesses.
It's all I know.
It's who I am.
It's the same way when I see a teacher,
or an artist, or anybody.
When I can see through their soul,
that they were meant to
cook, or paint, or build,
or whatever it may be.
I get such happiness.
It's the same reason that people
that I went to school with
who make $53,000 a year,
but I know they're so happy,
because it's what they want.
They want to be home at 5:00 PM.
They want to be on multiple sports teams.
They want every weekend off.
They don't want the pressure.
Let me talk about pressure real quick.
Can I tell you why I stand here
in this incredible event,
where entrepreneurship is
being put on this pedestal,
something I dreamed of my whole life,
that would eventually be cool,
and I start my conversation
with heavy levels of practicality,
it is because this is
the thing I most fear.
When the last regime, school,
had its day, you could get good grades.
Fake environment.
Very easy to manipulate.
You could go work in a company,
and if that company fired
you or didn't do well,
you had somebody to blame.
You did not have to take
any of the responsibility,
or have the scarlet letter of losing
because you were part of a machine.
The greatest thing about being
a CEO founder entrepreneur,
is that when there is success,
you get a disproportionate
amount of the credit.
The problem with entrepreneurship,
is when it fails, you
have nobody to blame.
One of the things that
I'm most worried about
is when you are a purebred entrepreneur,
you don't care about losing.
The process is your religion.
Running the company is your oxygen.
When you are not,
and you're doing it for everybody else,
or because it's cool,
when you fail, you will
have no place to hide,
and your loss will be very
public and unavoidable.
The reason I put so much pressure
on people being self aware
is if you're a natural
number two, six, 13, or 27,
the negatives of being a number one,
are overwhelming and very
difficult to quantify.
You have to ask yourself today,
that when your business fails,
are you okay with the judgment
of your family, friends,
your social media followers,
and the entire world,
and if you are, then you
can move on your merry way,
but if you are not,
one of the great ramifications
of this golden era of entrepreneurship,
is going to be the enormous
amount of depression
and mental illness when
99% of the businesses fail.
That concerns me.
(audience applause)
My friends, please don't misunderstand me.
I don't stand up here and say,
I'm an entrepreneur, you're not.
I say, that what this
phenomenon has taught me,
where I can go to the most
amazing places on Earth
and many people know who I am
is that my timing for
what I loved, worked out.
I take no pride in that.
I understand that it's circumstantial,
but I also know,
that this is why I'm so desperate
for you to stick to your
guns around your passion.
Maybe you actually love
playing video games
more than starting an app company.
When I was growing up,
playing video games was a waste of time.
Today, I think we can all agree,
a professional e-sports
superstar for the next 50 years,
probably behind proper
football and basketball
is going to be the biggest
athlete in our world.
This is nothing you could see
seven or 10 years ago.
You must, you must,
you owe it to yourself,
to make sure that you're
building a company
around what you love.
Not because cryptocurrency
is the current fad.
When you chase money, you lose.
Always and forever, even
when you achieve the money.
This is how humans are wired,
and so we have to have dramatically
more thoughtful conversations,
around entrepreneurship, start up culture,
and what's actually
happening in the world,
because right now, most of the unicorns,
are just rhinoceroses in disguise.
(audience applause)
Please don't get it confused.
I like every other person,
have my selfish wants and needs.
That last statement, that was selfish.
D-Rock, where you at?
I did that right now.
The unicorn for
rhinoceroses for one reason.
I know that 95% of the
successful internet companies
that we all put on a pedestal,
are so over leveraged,
against the reality of their business,
that when there is an
economic slow down or collapse
and they can't raise capital,
against a ridiculous
valuation, they will disappear.
Not because I'm smart.
It's because I'm old.
The one great thing about being 43,
is I've lived through three collapses.
A lot of people think.
How many people here under 32 years old?
Raise your hands.
Geez.
(audience laughing)
The biggest gift and the
biggest vulnerability
is that you're 32.
The biggest thing that,
there are so many things
running through my mind.
Number one, one of the
most fascinating things
running through my mind,
looking at the NIMEA area,
and looking at North
Africa, the Middle East,
it's devastating to me,
how much of the young talent here
thinks they need to go to America
or other places to achieve their goals
when there is so much opportunity.
(audience applause)
I mean it,
and if you're like me,
and you love your family,
I wasn't even willing
to move to Los Angeles,
because I needed to be
close to my mom and dad.
The thought of going to
another part of the world
when the disproportionate opportunity
is doubling down on your
region is fascinating to me.
It's a credit to the
thing I most care about
which is brand building.
America's great achievement
in the last 100 years
is using Hollywood to build its brand.
Please do not get confused.
There is so much opportunity
within a square mile of your home,
let alone the rest of the region,
that you do not need to be naive
and think you need to go
somewhere to achieve your goals,
because I'm jealous that I'm not under 32
sitting here with the outlook that I have.
When you look at the mobile penetration.
The percentage of the youth.
When you just look at
the sheer opportunity
that is in the general
region, it's extraordinary.
Too many people underestimate
what's in front of them
and over estimate what's outside of them.
I mean it.
(audience applause)
Let's bounce around a little bit.
I'm gonna take it to a
slightly different direction,
because I think it's unbelievably inherent
to so many people in this room.
I generally believe,
and by the way, not
everybody should do video.
Not everybody should do video.
Have somebody following
them around with a camera.
Not everybody should do video.
However, if you're
sitting here in the room,
front row, last person back there,
if you are not producing content
for the world on the internet,
whether that's because
you're a tremendous writer,
and you can write on your own blog,
on Medium, on LinkedIn, on Facebook.
Pictures because you're
unbelievably visual.
You can take a beautiful photo
and then write a wonderful
three or four sentences
on your Instagram post.
If you're stunningly
handsome and charismatic,
and you can do video, please,
but if you are great at talking,
but uncomfortable in front of a camera
and you have to do audio in podcast form,
please understand my
biggest truth here today
which is if you are not
sharing your thoughts,
your process, your journey,
your progress to achieving your goals,
the stories you want to tell
about your startup, product, service.
If you are not communicating to the world
and if you're not thinking about
what's valuable to them,
not what's valuable to you,
when you communicate, and
that is a very big point.
I'll say it one more time.
If you are not communicating to the world,
and when you're communicating.
If you're not thinking about
what's valuable to them
versus what you're
putting out for yourself,
you are basically
irrelevant in a 2019 world.
As much as it may be difficult
for many in this room,
if you are not living through here,
you are not known.
This is the game.
Unfortunately or fortunately,
I don't know how you
see technology advances.
I'll surprise you.
I'm not so pro technology revolutions.
I'm just practical.
My friends, at 18 years old,
me, at 18 years old,
had spent less than
two hours on a computer
in my entire life.
I am not fascinated by technology at all.
3-D printing.
I don't care if you make 80%
of your homes 3D printed.
I'm not passionate about that.
VR, AR, Blockchain, all of it.
Not really passionate to me.
I'm passionate about communication,
and that's where this happens.
If you are underestimating this,
and when I say underestimating this,
if you have not made a
significant commitment
to producing content for
the one of seven apps
or websites that 80% of this entire region
spends a disproportionate amount of time
penetrating, and listening, and consuming,
you are becoming vastly,
vastly, irrelevant.
If you leave with anything from this talk,
number one, please lean
in to self awareness.
There is so much delusion
running through this conference
and this region and this world,
it's devastating, because
it will not end well.
Number two, once you
establish that self awareness,
you must speak.
Everybody speaks differently.
Through pictures, words, audio, video,
but you must speak.
You must speak because that is absolutely
the leverage that you sit with.
We're sitting in the time right now
where across this region,
there's so much opportunity.
There's so much attention in a YouTube,
Snapchat, Instagram,
Facebook, Twitter world.
It's unparalleled.
There's never been a time
where every person in this room
with nobody in the middle,
has the ability to
reach anybody they want.
My friends, actually how many
people over 40 in this room?
Raise your hands.
Over 40.
I wish, and I'm sure,
I'm looking at a bunch of you right now.
There is a complete misunderstanding
of the disproportionate opportunity
that everybody in this room has.
All of us who are over 40 dreams
that we entered a world
with this many options.
We were stuck in the machine,
where there's one or two paths.
There was no options.
You are crippled by options.
You are crippled by options,
which now leads me to the most
important part of this conversation.
The number one thing that
I think about every day
is why do people live their lives,
based on other people's opinions?
The number one thing that
I really want to have.
How many people here under 30?
One more time.
Raise your hands.
The number one thing I wish
for everybody who just raised their hand,
is my ability to spend a two hour dinner
with your parents.
In that dinner would be the
most interesting insight.
Especially regions like this.
It is fascinating how
many people are dealing
with the pressures of what
their parents want them to do.
Versus what you want to do.
(audience applause)
Woo is right,
and the reason you're wooing,
and the reason that I'm most fascinated,
is I am fascinated by watching parents
parent their children in the exact way
that they hated their
parents parented them.
(audience applause)
It's remarkable to watch.
You would think somebody who was forced
to go to University and become a doctor,
lawyer, engineer, banker,
all that pain and anguish
that those years created.
You would think that they were capable
of not repeating it,
but the problem is the
great insight of my life
is how many parents parent their children
only and 100% based on
what other parents think
about their children.
This is the most important
topic in this region.
In a world, specifically to this region,
where there is so much opportunity.
The paradigm shift that is needed
is one on the parenting level
to create the freedom for children
to be able to become happy.
Not check the box of what
they're supposed to do.
(audience applause)
Now, before all the 30
year olds clap and say,
hell yeah Gary, before that,
there's one part of the equation
for all the children that are
so happy with this framework.
If you take your parents
money, they're in charge.
(audience applause)
I love to talk about,
you should go do your thing.
You should live your life for you.
I'm passionate and I believe this.
That I much rather most of
you have two or three years
where you're fighting with your parents,
but then have 50 years of happiness,
because you're not living with regret.
I'm passionate about that.
The problem is, I've been blown away,
by how many kids think they
can go start their own company
while their parents pay
for their lifestyle.
You either live on your
own two feet or you do not.
(audience applause)
99% of the startups back there will fail.
99, 97.
The amount of people that
ever achieve a business
that there's a million
dollars a year in revenue
is almost non existent.
Yet, we live in a world now,
where everybody thinks 50% of people
are going to build a
billion dollar company.
Optimism is foundational
for entrepreneurship.
Unless you are blindly
optimistic of your idea
you'll never get it off the ground,
because everything around you will say no.
Delusion is the great vulnerability
of starts ups and entrepreneurs.
Being practical and realistic
and being optimistic
is very feasible.
Unfortunately it is rare.
If I could ask anything,
how many people here have a
startup, or are an entrepreneur?
Raise your hands.
If I could ask anything of those,
please start converting your business
into something that actually makes money.
Not is in the need of funding,
because when you look at the framework
of what's happening globally,
we can't survive this much longer,
being this globally over leveraged,
and when it falls, it falls hard.
It fell hard in 2007 and 2008.
You guys know.
It fell hard in 2001.
It falls hard and this is the most
over leveraged we've ever been.
Please, if you leave with anything,
besides self awareness,
please leave with am I
prepared to turn my business
into something that generates profit?
Not is checking the box
for the amount of users
or CAT or LTV, or monthly downloads,
or all the things that
venture capitalists,
and funding want you to do.
In a game where those people
are playing a very simple game.
You have to understand
what investing is about.
They need to push every one
of their products very hard,
because if one gets through,
it pays for everybody else.
The problem is if you're
one who got pushed too hard
and didn't build an actual business,
you didn't win.
The fund won,
because one of the 50 companies did.
We need a call to practicality.
We need a call to
practicality in our ecosystem
because without it, the
outcome is always ugly.
Also when you've had such
a long period of global,
and I know there's different
markets and I understand,
but global prosperity at this level
without any fiscal accountability.
Just a matter of time.
My call this morning, this afternoon,
is a couple things.
Is this really the game you want to play?
Because let me remind you,
I'm awfully jealous.
A lot of my friends who are
number three, seven, 20, and 41
at Facebook and Uber and
all the other companies
that did well.
Number two, how practical
is your business?
Have you succumb to the
jargon of start up world?
Where everything is about
users and viewability and CAT
and all these terms that
have nothing to do with
are you making more money
than you're losing every month?
Let me tell you how much talent it takes
to lose money every month consistently.
Zero.
It takes zero talent to lose tens
if not hundreds of thousands
of dollars every month
while you're building to your exit.
It looks good on a chart,
except the chart isn't real.
What does that lead me to?
That leads me to the opportunity.
I'm gonna get very practical with you.
If you as a person or you as a business,
are not buying Instagram story ads,
in this region right now.
Right now, in this region, UAE,
across the Middle East, North Africa,
if you are not doing
that right this second,
you are making an enormous mistake.
I am the bi-product of buying
under priced ads my whole career.
My dad's liquor store,
that I grew from 30 to 60 million dollars
in five years with no money,
is because Google Adwords
were five cents a click
and nobody else was buying them.
I Gary V, the character,
was because I was buying ads on Twitter
when they were under priced,
then YouTube, and currently today,
on Instagram stories.
On this Arabic Gary V. account,
if you want to go look at any website
that shows the graph of growth.
This is very meta.
This is unbelievable timing.
This is my biggest thesis.
I see a lot of you shaking your head.
That means you consume my content.
Under priced attention.
Buying ads.
But this is probably the
most excited I've ever been
to talk about it, because this account,
Arabic Gary V. literally,
literally 10 days ago had 700 followers.
It now has 30,000 followers.
It had nothing to do with
me being in the region.
How much?
42,000.
Thank you brother.
(audience applause)
Don't clap.
Clap for yourself when you do what I did.
From 700 to 42,000 on one thing.
We found on Instagram stories,
a piece of content from a
quote or two that I had,
converted into Arabic.
Bought across Arabic speaking
people across the world,
where I am converting
followers for 1.9 cents.
If you've been in the ad game,
I'd be thrilled for 1.9 cent impressions.
I would lose my mind
for 1.9 cent engagement
which would be a like or passing it on.
To be able to get to 1.9
cent followers is ludicrous.
I've never seen it.
When my teen texted me a week ago
and said weird, we have some news.
Your Arabic page is exploding.
We found 1.9 cent followers.
I replied and told them to
spend all of my money on it.
All of it.
You and this is very meta,
you, will watch my
notoriety in this region
over the next nine months,
go through the roof.
Here's why.
Even though I just told
all of you to do it,
99% of you will not.
This is the story of my life.
Even though I just told you, 99% of you,
that the number one under
priced move in the region,
regardless of your business,
is to buy Instagram story ads
and make a lot of different content
until you find something
that's working for you.
I am convinced out of the
last 10 years of my life
that 99% of you will not
do anything about it.
Which will allow me to keep achieving
very under priced attention.
If only half of you started to run
meaningful ads on Instagram
stories in this region,
that price would triple or quadruple.
This is the great fascination of my life.
Even when told, verbatim,
black and white, in your face,
exactly what to do, somehow
miraculously, you will not.
- [Man] I will!
- You promise?
Stand up.
Let's clap it up for him!
(audience applause)
He will!
Now let's clap it up for his shirt.
Look at that shirt.
Clap it up.
I like that.
It's really fascinating.
That is what's happening,
and that is the great misnomer.
That is the great opportunity.
That is the great vulnerability.
We look at the past and
put it on a pedestal
and we look at the current and the future
and we demonize it.
I'm fascinated by that.
We look at technology advances
and we demonize it.
Yet, it is the only place we're going.
In America, a very big trend,
especially for affluent
parents on the coasts
is to limit the time their
children are on technology.
I want my children to
only live on technology.
Thanks Mom.
The reason I do that,
is because that's the world
my kids are gonna live in.
The horses are not coming back.
I am fascinated by people's inability
to lean into the current.
Who calls anybody anymore?
How many people here, tell
the truth by show of hands,
get mad when somebody
actually calls them now.
Raise your hand.
Stand up.
Stand up if that's.
Stand up, please.
I just want you to stand up.
I want to see this visual.
Stand up.
I'm gonna give you another second.
Don't lie.
Stand up if you are actually bothered
by somebody calling you.
Stand up.
Tell the truth.
Look around.
Everybody look around.
This was the most common
way we talked six years ago.
Please sit.
We're now literally,
if somebody calls you,
you look at it and you're like,
hello, Mom, why are you calling me?
This is because the number one thing
that I trade on is time.
Friction is the biggest vulnerability.
For a lot of people in
the internet business
this is why UX, UI, design,
all this stuff matters so much.
Any friction you cause is devastating.
The second wi-fi is a
hundredth of a second slower
than you're used to.
You are devastated.
Voice is going to be the next frontier,
and the same way that everybody here
used to call but now texts,
because time is so valuable,
and it is actually common courtesy
to why you're not calling.
Calling somebody now without
telling them you're calling
is an invasion on their time.
Soon voice will replace that.
If you really want to be
on the cusp of what's next,
I genuinely believe that Alexa,
and Google Home and voice activated UI,
is going to be unbelievably powerful.
It is a very very vibrant place.
It is.
That's one place to talk
and pay attention to,
but this all rounds up to
a very simple conversation
which is if you look
at the history of time
for entrepreneurship, for the human race,
there's all leads to one
road which is timing.
Timing.
It's unbelievable how much timing
plays a factor in all of this.
So many people back
there and in your heads
are playing too much in the future.
Three years ago all my friends
spend all their money
on VR, virtual reality.
Meanwhile I didn't know one person
who spent an hour on virtual reality
a month consistently.
So many people talk
about the future timing.
Of course AR, machine learning, VR,
all this stuff is coming,
but until you see it with real people
it's an enormous leap,
and you're gonna get your timing wrong.
On the same token,
the things I'm passionate about.
When I talk about Facebook
or Instagram or Snapchat
it is only because it's current.
In four years I will
sit on stages like this
and I will laugh at everybody here
buying Instagram story ads,
because the market will catch up
and thus it will become over priced.
Both demand for the ads will rise.
So the price will go up,
and you'll stop paying attention,
because more ads will show up.
This timing, this trading, this pulse,
is the single most important thing,
once you understand who you are.
Please start paying much bigger attention
to consumer's behaviors, to timing.
I was interviewed right
before I came up here
and the woman said,
who do you pay attention to?
Who do you listen to?
I said nobody.
I don't read books.
I don't listen to podcasts.
All I do is read you.
Tonight, when I'm at the
airport on my way home,
I'm going to look at the
hashtag of this event
and I'm gonna see what you had to say
about the event.
I'm gonna see what you
had to say about me.
About the opening keynote.
After.
I consume you.
If you want to win in a consumer product.
Not B to B.
If you want to win in a consumer product,
I highly recommend you
start training yourself
to read the consumer.
Not a thought leader's point
of view on the consumer.
I would far prefer,
that you read every
comment about your content
and your space's content,
versus watching my content.
Every day of the week.
The reason I've had
such a successful career
is because I don't guess.
I do the work.
Then I execute.
Then I talk about it quickly.
That is my career.
The fact that we now live in a world
where consumer's point of view, opinions,
are being posted immediately
in real time is remarkable.
Do you know how many people here
want to build more
followers and influence,
yet don't reply to the
comments on their posts?
The sheer audacity,
that you want to get
bigger with the world,
yet, you don't have the time,
to reply or thank the 13 people
that give a crap about
you now, is laughable.
The quickest way I know somebody's
not on their way to being an influencer,
is based on their behavior
with their community publicly.
Please invest back into the
people that invest in you.
(audience applause)
I don't know if you heard,
but the reality of being a human being,
according to modern science,
is 400 trillion to one.
If you follow me for
the last couple years,
you know I'm obsessed with this,
because I can't wrap my head around it.
As somebody who likes math
as much as they like art,
the sheer thought that
it is 400 trillion to one
to become a human being,
is almost difficult for me to swallow
and leads me to my final
point which is mindset.
If you are sitting here,
and you are not driven 100% on gratitude,
you are misunderstanding
how impossible it is
to even be a human being.
The fact that you could have been
a rhinoceros or a tree or a ladybug,
it is so remarkable to me how
people have not quantified
the most basic thing.
How I sit here, I stand
right here in front of you
driven 100% on gratitude.
I am so thankful to even get
the chance to do anything.
Let alone what I'm doing.
I promise you, when you
wake up every morning,
you don't need a meditation pod.
You don't need a book.
You don't need a podcast.
You don't need me.
If you wake up and
actually say to yourself,
the likelihood of me having a life
is more rare than getting
struck by lightning 10 times,
you will put life in
perspective very quickly.
Dwelling or complaining or
crying about what you don't have
versus understanding and
leaning into what you do have,
is exactly the same way that I understand
that I wish all of you knew,
how much better it would
be to build a business here
than to move to Silicon Valley.
(audience applause)
There's no money.
There's no accolades.
There's no awards.
There's no amount of followers
that can subsidize actual happiness.
Actual happiness starts very internal.
It starts with how you see the world,
and then leads into who
are you listening to,
and then it goes into your actions.
The fact that 85% of this audience
raised their hands and they're under 30,
which makes me know
that they're gonna live
three more full lives
based on modern medicine,
makes me desperately try
to push everybody here
for perspective and patience
and right now everybody's
going way too fast.
Wants everything way too fast
and if I could get you to slow down
and pay attention,
then I would scratch the itch,
and I stand here,
not only driven by gratitude,
but I stand here today, my friends,
driven by guilt.
I have enormous, and I mean this,
an enormous level of guilt,
of how lucky I was to
be born with nothing,
to grow up with nothing.
To have to earn everything for myself
and most of all to have parents
that put me in a position to listen
to myself and nobody else.
I wish that on all of you.
I wish you nothing but
health and happiness
and please, please, rewind this talk,
because if you follow even a
percentage of the blueprint,
I think something good will happen.
Thank you very much.
(audience applause)
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I'm just gonna sign this book for him.
What's that, selfie?